Often had the experience of teaching,
we heard someone calling our name and
then realizing that wasn't really the
case and we just,
we move on and we forget about it.
Sometimes we notice coincidence like,
oh,
there were a couple of cars on the
street,
and again,
we pay no attention to it,
but for someone with schizophrenia,
these experiences take on a vastly
different.
A kind of a feeling.
So you might notice,
oh,
there were three red cars on the street
and instead of just forgetting about it,
you start thinking,
well,
why were there three red cars on the
street?
Maybe has something to do with me?
Maybe these people are actually coming
to to monitor me or do something that
would harm me.
And you start working through some kind
of plot or conspiracy related to that
coincidence that you noticed
symptoms that people are most familiar
with and schizophrenia are often hearing
voices or having paranoid delusions and
paranoid thoughts.
And we now know that in addition to
those kinds of symptoms,
many people with schizophrenia have have
trouble focusing,
paying attention and remembering things.
Many people you know,
talk about hearing voices and mean
different things,
so sometimes people will say,
Oh yeah,
when I'm thinking about what to do,
I hear a voice in my head that tells me
this would be the right thing to do or
this would be the wrong thing to do,
or or that gives me an idea,
and when individuals with schizophrenia
talk about hearing voices,
they describe it very,
very differently.
It's really a voice that they can't tell
the difference between that voice and a
voice coming from a person sitting right
next to them in a room and it sounds
absolutely real.
It sounds loud.
Sometimes it's so loud that they can't
stop paying attention to it and
sometimes the voices are just calling
their name,
but sometimes the voices are saying much
more complicated things.
Sometimes they're giving them commands,
telling them what to do.
Sometimes they're commenting on what
they're doing often in a negative or
derogatory way.
It comes as no surprise that the brain
is a complicated place.
There's information flying all over the
brain and the brain has to get that
information to the right place and
decide what to do with it and we think
that perhaps in schizophrenia,
some of the problems come because
information isn't getting to the right
place or sometimes when information does
get to the right place,
the brain doesn't know what it should
pay attention to and what it should
ignore.
This is really important in our everyday
lives.
You know,
we might hear a car alarm in the
background and we have to know not to
pay attention to that,
but we might also hear a baby crying in
the background and that probably is
something that we need to pay attention
to.
And so if your brain's not able to act
as an executive and say this is what's
important and what's not important,
it becomes very difficult to sort
through those everyday situations,
uh,
in ways that are really important for
living and holding down a job or
managing your life.
Seeing things visual hallucinations are
more uncommon.
Schizophrenia,
they do sometimes happen and sometimes
they take the form of people seeing
ghosts or seeing people who aren't
really in the room.
Sometimes they look at a picture and
they see something more than what the
picture shows a often something with
nefarious intent.
Uh,
those are the kinds of experiences that
individuals with schizophrenia will
sometimes,
uh,
describe some people have them,
some people don't,
even for people who have them,
they can come and go at times,
um,
but these other symptoms that we now
understand better and are starting to
recognize more,
they're much more fundamental to the
disease and they're much harder to deal
with.
And,
and those are the symptoms,
like having trouble paying attention,
having trouble remembering information
and having trouble being able to
organize your activities and switch from
one activity to another activity.
These are things which individuals with
schizophrenia start to find are harder
than they were before they became ill.
So all of a sudden they,
they have trouble paying attention in
class.
They have trouble focusing on what
they're reading.
They have trouble,
you know,
doing jobs that require them to switch
between one kind of thing and another
kind of thing quickly and that that
obviously stands in the way of people
being able to,
you know,
live their lives to the fullest,
being able to work,
being able to manage their household,
being able to manage their families and
family relationships.
And so those symptoms,
what we often call cognitive symptoms,
symptoms related to attention and memory
and concentration and focus.
They're really one of our biggest
challenges right now in schizophrenia.